[Music]
it's hard keeping track of what's going
on in the world of marvel superheroes so
we're here to help you with this handy
guide
here's every marvel movie coming out
after black widow from marvel studios
entries in the marvel cinematic universe
to sony pictures projects in the
universe of marvel characters
chongqi and the legend of the ten rings
is a starring vehicle for the mcu's
first asian hero
the titular xiangchi master of kung fu
destin daniel cressen is directing and
chinese canadian actor simu liu will be
holding down the title role
according to the xiang chi trailer the
film will find our hero being drawn into
the world of the ten rings
the terrorist organization that kidnaps
tony stark in iron man
and was mentioned by darren cross as a
potential buyer for the yellowjacket
technology
in ant-man it seems their intimidating
boss when woo happens to be both xiang
chi's dad
and the notorious villain the mandarin
and he wants his son to take his place
in the terror group
as you might assume xiang chi has a few
things to say about that
not to mention a lot of people to punch
we can't wait to see all the action
going down on september 3rd
2021 sony's universe of marvel
characters kicked off successfully with
venom
which cleaned up at the box office
despite critics not being as kind
considering that the movie brought in a
mind-boggling sum of 856 million dollars
a sequel was all but obligatory set up
by a credit scene with a villainous
woody harrelson
and a truly fantastic wig a sequel
titled venom let there be carnage will
see andy circus stepping in as a
director
telling the story of harrelson's cletus
cassidy character as he unleashes
carnage on eddie brock's world
according to circus a plot will pick up
over a year after the events of the
first film
with eddie brock attempting to readjust
her normal life with his symbiote to
roommate
only to get pulled back into another
chaotic conflict with an otherworldly
foe
venom let there be carnage is set for
release on september 24th
2021 marvel head honcho kevin feige has
teased the eternal story
will span tens of thousands of years
telling an epic story of the type we
haven't seen yet in the mcu
the film will be directed by chloe zhao
who won an oscar for best director for
her work on nomadland which also nabbed
the academy award for best picture
the titular heroes at the center of the
film were a group of superpowered beings
created eons ago
by the celestials in order to defend the
earth from the evil deviants
in the real world they're the brainchild
of the great jack kirby who created the
comic in the mid-1970s
it features a pact cast that includes
the marvel debuts of richard madden
angelina jolie kumayo nanjiani and more
featuring a bonus game of thrones
reunion with richard madden as icarus
and kit harington as the black knight
eternals touches down on november 5th
2021
the more we've learned about the third
mcu spider-man movie the less we
understand about where this series is
going
when jk simmons reprised his role as j
jonah jameson from sam raimi's
spider-man trilogy
during the end credits of spider-man far
from home we probably should have
suspected that something strange was
after
in the mcu now reports have emerged that
heroes and villains from previous
iterations of the spider-man series like
alfred molina's doctor octopus
jamie foxx's electro and maybe even toby
mcguire and andrew garfield
are all being pulled into this movie for
an inter-dimensional spider summit
i'm sorry you're saying there's a
multiverse well far from home teased the
multiverse that ultimately turned out to
be a ruse perpetuated by mysterio
this movie might be bringing in a
multiverse for real
ah that's a question
that's a question in addition to other
spidey characters benedict cumberbatch's
doctor strange
is also joining the cast and he may be
the key to understanding how all these
surprising casting announcements fit
together we'll learn exactly how all of
the various spider verses potentially
fit together
when spider-man no way home hits
theaters december 17
2021 joining tom hardy's eddie brock in
the sony spider-verse will be morbius
based on a living vampire and frequent
spider-man nemesis
who first appeared in the pages of
marvel comics in 1971.
morbius will star jared leto as dr
michael morbius
a brilliant biochemist whose attempts to
cure his own deadly blood disease with
an experimental vampire bat treatment
go predictably awry transforming him
into a superpowered ghoul who must
consume human blood to survive
the movie will also feature a surprising
appearance from michael keaton
most likely reprising his role as adrian
tombs aka the vulture from spider-man
homecoming
this film will hit theaters on january
28 2022.
in 2019 we learned that the doctor
strange sequel will be titled doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
the sequel will co-star elizabeth olsen
as wanda maximoff and it will be
directly influenced by the weird events
of one division
and possibly the events of loki joining
the cast of doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness
is babysitter's club star sochi gomes as
america chavez
also known in the comics as miss america
a member of the young avengers who also
happens to be from another dimension
the creative team for the second strange
film is changing in a big way
with spider-man trilogy director sam
raimi stepping in for original director
scott derrickson
we'll find out what else is changing in
the mcu with this one on march 25th
2022 taika waititi of thor ragnarok
will be returning to direct thor love
and thunder and also to voice the
lovable rock alien cork but at 2019 san
diego comic-con
further details were announced that
shocked those in attendance
specifically the ragnarok sequel will
see the return of natalie portman's jane
foster
he will follow in her character's recent
comic book footsteps by picking up meow
nir to become thor herself
additionally several of the guardians of
the galaxy will also be reportedly
joining the cast
which makes sense considering thor was
last seen joining the guardians
at the end of avengers end game serving
as the antagonist for love and thunder
will be christian bale as gore the god
butcher
a character who in the comics is
obsessed with killing gods and absorbing
their power
how it comes together will all be
revealed when thought love and thunder
hits theaters on may 6
2022 after the tremendous success of
2018's black panther
a sequel was a sure thing with chadwick
boseman expected to reprise his role as
t'challa
the king of the fictional country of
wakanda tragically in august of 2020
bozeman passed away following a
four-year struggle with cancer
the news came as a shock to bozeman's
fans and colleagues alike
as the actor had kept his condition and
treatment quiet
even as he continued to work while
marvel declined to comment too
specifically on the future of black
panther immediately following bozeman's
death
black panther wakanda forever is moving
forward with the rest of the cast and
crew
dedicated to honoring bozeman's memory
the anticipated bittersweet sequel is
set to be released on july 8th
2022 no spider-man film before it was
ever able to do what sony pictures
animation spider-man into the
spider-verse did
win an academy award the best animated
feature of 2018 is considered by some to
be among the greatest superhero films
ever made
with its supremely innovative animation
style and focus on its eclectic cast of
ultimate universe spider people its
success seems impossible to duplicate
but sony is still going to try the
spider-verse sequel will center on the
burgeoning romantic relationship between
miles morales and gwen stacy
reportedly taking place two years after
the events of the first film
additional plot details are still a
mystery but a teaser shared by
the official spiderverse twitter account
flickers through several different
spider logos
which seems to indicate that once again
we'll be meeting a variety of different
spider people from across the multiverse
one thing we do know is that each array
of hbo's insecure
will be playing jessica drew better
known as spider woman
as for which other heroes will be
joining the flick we'll find out soon
enough
as into the spider verse 2 hits theaters
on october 7th
2022 while marvel is keeping quiet
so far about what carol danvers will be
up to the next time we see her
we do know that she won't be alone the
film that was originally presented as a
sequel to 2019's captain marvel
was revealed in 2021 to actually be a
team up feature
titled the marvels brie larson will be
returning as carol danvers aka captain
marvel
the titular star of the first film but
joining her this time around will be
tiana paris
who was introduced in one division as a
grown-up version of monica rambo
and iman valani who will be appearing in
her own disney plus series as carol
danvers number one fangirl kamala khan
aka ms marvel a team up adventure will
be soaring into theaters on november 11
2022 while most of the other mcu titles
for disney plus seemed intended to
further the overarching interconnected
plot for phase 4 and beyond
marvel announced one title during
disney's 2020 investor day event
that doesn't seem interested in epic
battles or sprawling narratives
and is much more concerned with being
jolly and bright
that's right the guardians of the galaxy
holiday special is coming to disney plus
in 2022
what can we expect from a holiday themed
mcu space special
one may need to look no further than the
much maligned star wars holiday special
which guardians writer and director
james gunn says he unironically loved as
a kid
what's up gunn says he's had the idea
for a guardian's holiday special for
years
and that is one of his favorite stories
ever the special will be live action and
will bring back
all of the main guardians cast members
gunn also confirmed that the special
will be considered mcu canon
and it will be set between the events of
thor love and thunder and
guardians of the galaxy vol 3. it's
still hard to picture exactly what to
expect from the holiday special
but we'll find out in late 2022
among the more interesting projects sony
has planned for their spidey-centric
universe is a solo vehicle starring the
classic villain
sergey kravenoff aka craven the hunter
descended from an aristocratic russian
bloodline kravinov has dedicated his
life to becoming the world's greatest
hunter
and no quarry has ever stoked his
obsession quite like spider-man
while we're unsure of the plot we know
the screenplay will be penned by the
equalizer 2 scribe richard wenk
and screenwriting duo art markham and
matt holloway
interestingly back in 2018 before marcum
and holloway came aboard
wayne had some interesting ideas about
the project in an interview with
discussing film the writer said
it's an interesting world a great
character it's going to adhere very
closely to the law of craven the hunter
and he is going to come face to face
with spider-man
we don't know if that's true but we do
know who will be playing craven
mcu veteran aaron taylor johnson who
portrayed the ill-fated quicksilver in
avengers age of ultron
raven the hunter will be helmed by
triple frontier director
jc chandler and is scheduled to hit
theaters january 13th
2023 after playing a key role in saving
the entire universe during the events of
avengers end game
and man will return for a third
headlining feature ant-man on the wasp
quantum mania
of the three core director peyton reed
promised the third ant-man movie is
going to be a much bigger more sprawling
movie than the first two
it's going to have a very different
visual template returning for quantum
mania are franchise stars paul rudder
scott lang
and evangeline lilly as hope van dyne
along with hope's father and scott's
mentor hank pym
and the long-lost wife he recently
rescued from the quantum realm janet van
dyne
joining the cast will be catherine
newson as a teenage version of scott's
daughter
cassie who was briefly played by emma
furman in avengers endgame
in the comics cassie becomes a superhero
stature one of the early members of the
young avengers
plus lovecraft country star jonathan
magers will be playing iconic marvel
baddie kang the conqueror
one of marvel's most notorious and
powerful villains
expect to see our heroes battle their
new foe on february 17th
2023 between getting fired and rehired
by disney over
some old tweets james gunn decamped to
warner brothers to write and direct his
own take on the suicide squad
but he's coming back to finish what he
started with guardians of the galaxy vol
3. we don't know much about the plot of
the movie but considering where things
left off we assume it will have
something to do with the guardian
searching for gamora we also know rocket
raccoon will be a major player
as gunn explained on twitter rocket is a
big part of what's happening in the
future
and a lot of this stuff like the scars
we're about to see on his back sets up
what i've been planning for rocket all
along
as it now stands guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 will be entering our orbit on may
5th
2023 these aren't the only marvel
studios and sony pictures projects on
the state for the years to come
also reported to be in development with
no announced release dates are
deadpool 3 fantastic four
blade captain america iv
an untitled or female spider-verse
spin-off
nova jackpot
an entitled olivia wilde project
reportedly centered on spider-woman
an entitled sj clarkson project
reportedly centered on madame webb
black cat silver sable night watch
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the future of the marvel cinematic
universe are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one